[Music]
morgan is with us in pittsburgh hi
morgan how are you
hi i'm good how are you
better than i deserve what's up
so i've had a question my boyfriend and
i um
we
just not kind of recently graduated
college where i'm a year and a half out
and he's two years out and i have a lot
of student debt and he has a little bit
in a car payment and we're trying to
eventually move out of my parents house
and we're just wondering the next big
steps we could take to tackle all our
debt
you both graduated
yeah
i agree he graduated two years ago and i
graduated may 2020.
so what do you make how much money do
you make
i make 70 grand a year and he makes
roughly 65.
okay
all right
so you have 135 000 household income if
you were married
correct okay
so
go get married
tell him that i've been waiting on it
well he needs to move out if he's not
gonna get married
yeah i know we both live at my parents
house luckily so we don't have any i
know he needs to move out if he's not
gonna get married
no i'm serious
uh you can't you know
i gotta tell you here's the here's the
statistical evidence
all right the number of people who do
what you all are doing and succeed
financially
is almost zero
okay
everybody talks about it but nobody does
it so
if you want the formula to win there's a
thing called the marriage advantage in
the financial world
and we see people who are married
prosper over those who are not
there's a marriage advantage health
increases everything and so yeah i i
would get married the first thing i
would do and then you have 135 000
household income i don't know why you
would be living at your mother's in that
situation you'd go get a an apartment
and then you would attack your student
loan debt and making 135 000 how quickly
can you pay off a step pretty dead gum
quick if you start concentrating on it
right
when you clean up both student loans how
much student loan debt have you got
again
i have a lot i have a hundred and fifty
thousand he only has twenty thousand
okay so 170 000 combined and how much
other debt
um
that's all i have and then he has a
truck payment our
truck loan for 20 000.
okay so 190 000 gets you guys out of
debt if you keep the truck
all right
and you make 135
if you're married
and you live on nothing you could do
this in under three years probably
approaching two years
you could be 100 debt free
with moving out yeah
yeah you're not gonna run anything fancy
you're gonna rent something that's not
fancy
you don't need anything fancy you
suggest
renting then oh definitely you're broke
okay you're 190 000 in debt you don't
need to buy a house
right because i know
at first like of course you have parents
and family everyone's going you know
don't rent don't rent buy so we've
always had like buying in our house at
least the same people told you to get
190 000 in debt
yeah yeah so i don't think i'm taking
their financial advice anymore they're
not bright
yeah you need to get this mess cleaned
up because if you don't have any
payments at all
you're married
two years and from now three years from
now no payments at all and you're making
135 by then you'll be making more
making 150 000 a year you can save up
and buy a house pretty quick can't you
and crap you're only 23 24 years old
right
yeah correct yeah so i mean we're
talking at 25 26 you start talking about
buying a house and you'll be able to put
down a huge chunk because you're used to
living on nothing
and paying off that
so my next question is because then i
have about roughly 20 in my savings and
he has roughly 34. oh good this is going
to go even faster than because we're
going to throw all of that at the debt
okay that was my next question and i
know i've just recently actually found
your instagram page and i've watched the
steps
um so technically i guess we're at step
two because we could take some of that
and have our small emergency fund so
then you suggest you're just listening
if you were married you would just list
your debts all of these we've talked
about the 190 000 smallest to largest
and you would apply the 70 000 worth of
savings to the smallest ones until it
ran out
okay i got you down to a thousand bucks
now that's all after you get moved and
you know you're going to put up some
deposits and that kind of stuff and
you're going to pay for the marriage
license
are you seeing a theme here i keep
talking about you getting married did
you get that thing i know i hope he's
listening
yeah
i hope he is too because if he's not you
ought to kick him out
i know
i'm gonna tell him you told me so yeah
yeah i mean he needs to start let's man
up here if this is your woman dude let's
call it okay do it let's move forward
it's time to start acting like adults
not 14 year olds and let's get some
stuff done here you can do it you can do
it you're smart you're smart people
you're you're not dumb y'all make good
money at 23 years old i mean you're
really
you're really bright and you've done
really well but you're making some money
you're making you know you're you're
emotionally
living below your age
because you're in your mama's basement
playing shack up
instead of getting married and going and
being two adults as a married couple
grown people
yes and so
i'm trying to push you out of the nest
here for your own good because that's
where you'll prosper
when you guys throw your shoulders back
like two adults and get after this
you're going to see some huge progress
and lock arms and be the first big
joy of your new marriage is to be able
to clean this mess up and move on i'm
proud of where you're going to be at 25
already i think it's going to be awesome
and i'm just being pushy to get you
there for you doesn't do me and it
doesn't do anything for me
i want to get you there matter of fact
i'm going to go ahead and give you a
wedding gift
uh i want you to go through financial
peace university
uh and i'm going to sign you up for a
year with your new husband uh for ramsey
plus and uh
and uh get them in there and we'll get
this going